tell me about your family me dad worked
in the bush and mom you know she's out
and about
hi everyone my name is Jack Wallace I'm
a dialect coach here in Hollywood and
today I'm gonna figure out who has the
real authentic Australian accent
hi my name is Hayley and I'm Australian
hello my name is Bret Larkin on
Australian hi my name's Ella and I'm
Australian the placement of the tongue
pays a big role in the Australian accent
they tend to use slightly different part
of the time to form the bowels compared
to English and American people it's
especially in the diff songs which means
there's two sounds in a vowel
- o sound and a sound especially for
example okay in English o K goes oh the
diphthong that way in American it goes
the other way oh okay in Australian it
goes I so it uses like the middle part
of the tongue rather than the back that
I sound for example ice cream people
tend to overshoot and end up with ice
cream rather than ice cream we want
something in the middle where you use
the middle part of your tongue
aye-aye-aye
ice cream let's bring the people from
down under up here
[Music]
let's start right here come on up
hello so what what what is your name my
name's Bret Larkin from Australia how
long have you been in America of billion
American for about five years
tell me about your family we did worked
in the bush and mom you know she's out
and about all time hanging with the kids
doing their hair stuff if you were to
name the last and the first day of the
week what would they be Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday
thank you talking about yeah my spot now
oh yeah I think you come up hey what is
your name
get a nice lovely speedy Ayla and how
long have you been in America I've been
in America also five years great I feel
like this mischief afoot what do you
like to do I like to read I love plants
I love visiting gardens and banging
outside nice I love to eat I love veggie
my oh well we got to get a stray lien
culture here I feel like this a very
heavy-handed push but I'm from Australia
in this ad set well you tell me the days
of the week Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday
excellent thank you very much
it feels like she has a kind of hit the
red light but kind of a less
stereotypical Australian accent that are
the like slight I sounds in there
without it becoming I this potential
here
and she said Vegemite excellent and what
what is Yannick Haley excellent and how
long have you been in America five years
oh great everyone's been here for five
years what can you tell me about your
family
my mom's a teacher and my dad's an
accountant and I have two brothers ah
excellent and how old are your brothers
are they younger younger the middle one
is 21 and the youngest one is 13 Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday okay we're going into
the final round I'm only gonna have 30
seconds with each person to figure out
who is telling the truth and who is
alive excellent for this version I'm
gonna get everybody to say the same
phrase the phrase I would like you to
say is six sheep sleep on three ships
six sheep sleep on three ships six sheep
sleep on three ships six sheep sleep on
three ships I just need to test these
two people one more time okay I've got
to give you some very typical Australian
words to say just to see how they sound
coming out of you whether they sound
like foreign words to you or whether
they sound like oh yeah this is this is
language I use all the time these are
dialect things I use all the time the
phrase I would like you to say is
strewth it's blinky bill truth thank you
Bill now just imagine that there's a
koala in front of you and you're shocked
about it and give it me one more time
it's true
it's blinky bill alright great thank you
you sir may have your same phrase you
see a koala unexpectedly
strewth it's blinky bill strokes is
blinky bill excellent
and one more time just naturally like
arts truce truce is velikiy bell alright
thank you very much I think I've come to
my decision of who the real person may
be the reason why I choosing this person
is because they were very contained
within their own accent the whole time
whereas I feel like some of the others
had to see that sounds at some point and
then veered off at other points where
this person was consistently within the
same accent two people were a little
wandering within their signature sounds
now they could have been doing this to
throw me off you know the person I think
that was consistently within the same
sound groups the whole time is Ayla
[Music]
oh I am so glad I got it right I could
continue working in this field and not
feel ashamed when he asked me to say is
the whatever thing about the Koala I was
like the hell is back facts that was a
lot of fun actually it was a lot of fun
to listen to the other two they said
that had me really trying not to fall on
the ground
my dad works in the bush
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]